oh that's my hundred thousand dollars
$500,000
will you give your hubby for his
birthday when your car D be a half a
million dollars cash yeah you heard me
five hundred thousand dollars cold hard
cash on Saturday the rapper shared this
video of herself on Instagram surprising
her man with the over-the-top crazy
generous gift for his 28th birthday say
new everyone's saying you got every car
you got archery you got every own
alright thank you got your shoes you
know what else can I give somebody that
I earthy the bridge you can see where
this is going right might be a beautiful
thing did ya cardi stashed that cash in
the fridge the fridge
[Music]
who needs wrapping paper and ribbon when
you can just keep that gift crisp in the
fridge the fridge but anyway all set
loved it avi no I'm saying I don't know
what to give you so I suppose I gotta
get you saying you could buy a car you
could buy more clothes
goodbye jewelry you could buy me more
Birkin bags you could do whatever you
want if he doesn't want it I'll take it
now here's where the stars they're just
like us since offsets birthday is so
close to Christmas cardi said he
shouldn't expect a visit from Santa
happy birthday and don't don't exact
don't that no business for me
yeah I love you but the half a mil
wasn't the only way car D celebrated her
hubby's birthday the two also partied it
up in LA with a lot and we mean a lot of
strippers offset shared this pic of
himself fully surrounded and straddled I
might add with the caption quote happy G
day to the greatest of all time last
night was lit and just check out that
cake cardi opened up about her in
offsets relationship in the January
issue of Vogue the couple split after
offset cheated last year but they have
since gotten back together and have
faced a lot of heat on social media
quote my thing is everybody on social
media acts like relationships is perfect
and that's crazy to me I believe in
forgiveness breaking it out we always
gonna be a family that's together yeah
my baby love us both cardi added quote
we have come to a clear understanding
for me
monogamy is the only way I'll beat your
if you cheat on me cardi is a queen I
mean can we talk about what a boss move
it is to give hundreds of thousands of
dollars cash as a gift it was not even a
milestone birthday you guys of course
you can count on et to bring you all the
latest cardi and offset news so make
sure to keep it locked right here until
next time I'm Holly Stephens see you
soon okay
[Music]